see in Russia you say if you got one
choice you know what that mean you got
no [ __ ] choice hockey was the most
popular sport in the Soviet Union from
childhood they picked out the best of
the best of the best it was politics
really the game for them wasn't just the
game it was also propaganda the movie is
about the Soviet Union the greatest
sports dynasty arguably in history the
Red Army hockey team and the
interrelationship between sport politics
society and how they all kind of run
parallel gay Polsky is the filmmaker
behind the critically acclaimed
documentary red army which has just been
released after a wildly successful
festival run the film is a gripping look
at the rise and fall of the dominant
Soviet hockey team through the eyes of
one of the team's brightest stars it's
told from the perspective of the captain
the team Slava Fetisov national hero and
then became a political enemies a man
that you know fought for freedom and in
a very oppressive system and helped kind
of collapse the Soviet Union and the
rest of the world call us Red Machine or
Red Army but you will not machine me not
robots of course you know it's in the
movie now it was fight against communist
system - the freedom for the freedom of
choice for the democracy for the people
right and I've and I feel this in my
skin for tea sauce decision to fight the
restrictive and at times ruthless
policies of the communist regime
supplies the backbone of the film
culminating in the hockey star being
given the first multiple-entry work visa
to the United States and opening the
door for other Russian players to come
to the west because you know it's the
philosophy of the Iron Curtain was
people cannot go and work outside of
Soviet Union
I get American reason now that was first
Soviet citizen who got this privilege to
work in the United States so why did the
Soviets pour so much energy and
resources into their sports teams
fighting to keep their best players
inside the system for so long according
to Polsky
it all stems from a very clear agenda at
the heart of the Cold War I think sports
is an easy way to reach people and I
think the Soviet Union knew that they
knew that you know you can't fight a
nuclear war against the United States
and you know they wanted to spread the
Soviet ideology everywhere and and when
you see your team winning all the time
if people are gonna start turning their
heads and saying what the hell is going
on over there why are they so good that
must be you know their system must be
somehow better for the Soviets sports
were in a way a kind of warfare
the game for them wasn't just the game
it was also part of what you would call
propaganda actually making very clear
that we're the best and we're the best
because of the Soviet system because of
socialism that's why we're the best but
the Soviet sports system collapsed for
the same reasons the communist
government ultimately fell because at
the core of any top-down system are
individuals with their own goals and
desires so nobody push myself to Train
four times a day because you know I like
the communist system and support the
revolutions [ __ ] like that I mean it's a
play because I love the game work four
times today because I wants to be number
one in the world that's the different
philosophy Red Army is playing in
theaters now
you